my name is max pemberton i'm a doctor
and a journalist
and until a few years ago i was also a
very heavy smoker
while i didn't have great problems in
stopping smoking myself
i know that from my clinical practice
some people really struggle with
quitting
what's interesting is that with the
emergence of e-cigarettes
people are taking control of their
cigarette use in a really different way
about half of the people that use
e-cigarettes are using them to quit
entirely but the other half are using
them
long-term with no intention of quitting
at all
e-cigarette users argue that they enjoy
using it and that there's no
harm from long-term nicotine use so
should i be promoting this as an
alternative to smoking
i'm going to speak to professor claire
geraider former head of the royal
college of general practitioners
and a gp in south london with a special
interest in addiction
there are some people that will say you
know if you're addicted to nicotine so
what doesn't matter
you know nicotine is a harmless
substance it's not going to be
doing any damage to their health so what
does it really matter if they're
addicted
80 percent of people who have more than
two cigarettes
will be lifelong smokers so it is an
incredibly
addictive drug far more addictive than
heroin
far more addictive than many of the
other substances that young people will
take
this weekend i am abstinent from the
behavior of smoking
i do not have to worry about the end of
a meal
where can i have my e-cigarette i don't
have to worry at the end of a long
flight
oh gosh i can now have my e-cigarette i
am free
from all of that addictive behavior that
is a far better place to be
than carrying around an e-cigarette and
always having that cognition
that addictive mind i must get off this
plane
quickly i must get out of the restaurant
can i smoke an
e-cigarette so it is always better in my
mind as a doctor
to not medicalize i.e prescribe
e-cigarettes buy them
but rather to remove the behavior
claire takes a fairly hard-line medical
perspective
her view is that all addiction is bad
and that these people are still addicted
to nicotine while i understand her point
of view
i worry that we're losing sight of the
fact that
actually nicotine products save lives
as a doctor that's something i'm far
more interested in
than whether or not somebody's
technically an addict i wanted to get a
different
medical perspective so i'm going to
speak to dr roger
henderson he's a gp based in shropshire
and he's also a regular contributor to
spectator health
he's got a special interest in smoking
cessation and has been the face of
several nhs
quit campaigns roger as doctors should
we be
promoting abstinence as the answer to
nicotine addiction
in an ideal world yes the trouble is we
don't live in an ideal world and the
days when you had
smoker who smoked bad smoker who quit
good
have really gone and i think tobacco
risk reduction
tobacco harm reduction is now the
buzzword and so smokers that either
cannot quit
or choose not to quit should have access
to treatments
to maintain them away from their smoke
and smoking cigarettes
and if that means they remain on
nicotine replacement for a while or even
long term
personally i'm comfortable with that if
people want to use
nicotine replacement therapy in the long
term do you have a problem with that
i'm completely relaxed about that and
the reason is this
because it is not nicotine that kills
and maims our smokers
it is smoke what i want is for our
smokers to quit
smoke i don't really care if they don't
quit nicotine ideally they should
but if they're not smoking if they're
not putting smoke into their lungs
they're not harming themselves nicotine
essentially is no more
harmful to me or to you than that cup of
coffee we've just had
okay that's an important point and
people slightly get confused when they
think about nicotine they think nicotine
is harmful it is not
smoke kills our smokers not nicotine
roger takes a very pragmatic view of
nicotine addiction
for him from a harm reduction point of
view the development of things like
e-cigarettes has been a massive step in
the right direction
module is clear it's not nicotine that
kills people
it's smoking so smoking is what we
should all be focusing on
rather than tying ourselves up in knots
around whether or not somebody is
addicted to nicotine
for him abstinence is not the only way
what about the psychological aspects of
smoking there's no doubt
for lots of people cigarettes form a
really important
habitual aspect to their lives and also
is there any positive aspects of
nicotine does it have
any effects on the body at all or is it
an inert substance
professor dinesh bugra is the former
president of the royal college of
psychiatrists
and the current president of the world
psychiatric association
and he explains people who use nicotine
will say
you know it helps them with their
concentration helps them with you know
feeling relaxed and things like that
so are there any benefits to using
nicotine i think it's exactly that that
you know people do feel calm people do
feel
that they can concentrate better and
it's also you know the first
hit of the day which can you know gets
them going
but the point is not what it is
doing in the sense that you know the
kind of positive
aspects it's the addictive nature
and it's almost you know building on
more and more more you smoke more you
need and more you need
more you smoke so it just kind of builds
into
a long-standing long-term addiction
problem
although nicotine might not be
responsible for the deaths that we see
with
cigarette smoking that actually nicotine
does still have an effect on the brain
in some ways so it's not a completely
inert substance no it's not an inert
substance i mean it is a chemical
substance which affects
brain cells so i think that's something
that we need to
take on board and take it seriously what
is the impact
of using nicotine long term i think that
certainly there has been considerable
amount of evidence suggesting that it
affects people's
mental health and we know that people
who have mental illness uh
are more likely to use nicotine because
it kind of you know gets rid
of hallucinations and delusions and
makes them feel better but it also means
that it interferes with the medication
that they're on
and we also know that you know patients
bidsky disorders are likely to die 15 to
20 years younger than those who do not
so i think there are those kind of
long-term issues that we need to be
aware of and we need to keep an eye and
watch out for
there's no doubt that for many people
who use e-cigarettes or nicotine-based
products
that for them this is a civil liberties
issue they argue that they're not
hurting anyone
in fact there's no evidence that they're
even hurting themselves so why can't
they keep using these products
i've come to speak to rory broomfield
he's director of the freedom association
and i'm going to ask him to put forward
the civil liberties case
people need to be able to make the
choice over how they
live their lives and how they consume
products whether they be cigarettes
e-cigarettes or other therapies so the
point is
here that e-cigarettes provide the
choice for people to
either consume nicotine in that way or
indeed any other way how do you feel
though
about people using these products long
term
because obviously we're aware that some
people are using them to wean themselves
off nicotine but some people are making
a very active choice to continue using
them
with with no intention of stopping in
the shorter intermediate term
well of course there's an element of
education about
what they are consuming and i think the
medical profession
is trying to provide that information
but
ultimately it's about the individual
choosing whether or not he or she wishes
to
consume or buy an e-cigarette and indeed
the benefits of buying an e-cigarette
opposed to buying a cigarette i think
are well established
finally i'm going to speak to maura
gilchrist director of scientific
engagement at philip morris
i want to ask her about the company's
current research and development
activities
but also whether or not the general
public should really trust tobacco
companies to make an alternative
to the traditional cigarette what's the
focus
of your research and development
activities
well the focus of our research and
development activities
are really to develop to assess and
ultimately to commercialize
a portfolio of products that we believe
have the potential to reduce
smokers health risk and reduce the
health risk to the population overall
we're working on a range of different
products
some that contain tobacco and some that
don't but it's really the combustion of
tobacco
that causes the health-related issues
with cigarettes
it's that high temperature of burning
that causes the generation of the vast
majority
of the chemicals that appear in
cigarette smoke
and particularly the ones that are most
closely associated with
smoking-related diseases why are you a
tobacco company
looking to develop these safer
alternatives not only are we trying to
develop these products but it's our
ambition
ultimately they will completely replace
cigarettes
and people may question why would we be
doing that and make question what our
motives are
but we're doing this to respond to the
needs of smokers
and also ultimately to respond to the
serious concerns that
are known about smoking isn't it just as
bad for somebody to be
addicted to nicotine as it is for them
to just continue smoking
there are certain misconceptions about
nicotine but many public health bodies
including public health england from
here in the uk
they recognize that nicotine is one of
the reasons why smokers
use cigarettes so nicotine is addictive
it's not risk-free but they also
recognize that it's not the primary
cause of smoking-related diseases
if i'm honest many people don't trust
you
are these products not just an attempt
for you to keep your business
despite all the efforts they've been to
try and curb smoking
we understand that some will question
our motives why would we try and
transform what is already
a very profitable business for us
but ultimately this is what smokers are
demanding potentially reduced risk
products so it makes sense
for us as a business it makes sense for
our shareholders
and ultimately it's also completely
aligned with the goals of public health
when would you be in a position to make
a claim that your products
are reduced risk well the exact timing
of
a claim is difficult to predict our
scientific studies are well underway and
the results are encouraging
in fact we're so encouraged that we will
be submitting to the united states food
and drug administration through their
modified risk tobacco product
application process
and we'll be doing that towards the end
of this year
certainly i understand claire's argument
that being addicted to something
isn't nice but as roger alludes to
people choose to use nicotine based
products for a variety of reasons
and really as doctors it's our job to
direct them towards the safest way of
doing this
the stark fact is that smoking kills
half of the people
that smoke anything we can do that moves
people away from traditional cigarettes
has got to be a good thing
smoking kills people nicotine doesn't
for me abstinence is not the only way